welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for our presentation titled
simplifying component selection in
lateral flow assay development it is my
pleasure to introduce you to claus
hotchliner global technology lead in the
diagnostics of sativa for complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the tab at the top of your screen
if you have any questions that might
arise during the presentation we
encourage you to submit them in the q a
box our speaker will address your
questions following the end of the
presentation
please join me now in welcoming claus
hodgsoner i will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome sir
wait thank you for the introduction and
welcome to this presentation on
component selection and natural flow
assay development
letter flow essays
are rapid tests that are unrivaled in
terms to speed and ease of use
the point is that their development can
take an awful lot of time so typically
starting from the test idea over
component sampling and development and
design verification you can easily spend
up to 12 months and including stability
tests regulatory approval
validation scale up it may last a total
of two years
you want to get this step correct
and that means that you need to select
your components early and in the correct
way
in general a lateral flow test consists
of a couple of different materials
that serve different purposes
and the sample flows laterally through
these pads and membranes
and generate your test results
basically we discriminate between two
essay types
one type is called a sandwich test
that's been used if you can bind two
binders to your specific target molecule
blindness can be antibodies can be
antibody fragments can be aphamers or
aptamers the point is that you can bind
two of them independently to your target
and they do they do not interfere with
each other
the other option is a competitive test
in that case
you cannot bind more than one binder
to your target molecule and that means
you have a test line that already
contains your target molecule
and
in a negative sample
your antibody your detector antibody
will bind to that test line
and if the target is present in the
sample liquid you will see a decrease
the signal at the test line while in the
sandwich test you see an increase in the
signal the test line
both tests are being
used today
and as an example for a sandwich test
that's the well-known
pregnancy test and an example for a
competitive test would be a drugstore
abuse test
typically a later flow manufacturing
process consists of a number of
different steps so you coat the sample
pads and potentially blood separators
and conjugate pads with appropriate
buffers
you apply your detector conjugate to the
conjugate pad and dry you dispense your
chest and control lines onto the
membrane
if necessary you would code even the
wick
you will affix all components to a
self-adhesive backing card cover this
card with a translucent cover tape if
the tests to be sold as a dipstick or
you will cut the card into strips of
defined width and encapsulate these
strips in a cassette housing it's not to
be sold as a dipstick
so what we have here is a
multi-component system
the advantage of this magic clothing
system is that this test strip contains
all chemicals and reagents that are
required
and it contains them in the drive state
in most cases you need no sample
preparation at least let's say no
external sample preparation because you
can add a number of buffers to the
sample application pad which is the
first pad in your test
and force your sample to have a specific
iron strength or a specific ph
the enhues adjust adds the sample and
lets the test run until the results get
visible
and that means it can be handled by lay
people
the test result is appearing rapidly
a typical test duration time is
something between 5 and 15 minutes
the obvious disadvantage is it's a
multi-component system and it's very
challenging in development and
manufacturing
when you develop an lfa
labeled antibodies
or aphemers optomers
other binders like scrap evidence or
neutral vitamin
capture binders and the test membrane
are all integral to the success of a
lateral flow essay
and that means you have to have a
thorough selection process and you must
ensure that these components work
together
and you have to have an eye
on the properties of your sample liquid
and the specific of the target molecule
that you want to detect
selection optimization of binders is
important step but these binders
communicate with the membrane if you
want to say so
and that's sometimes not being
addressed correctly during lfa
development
let's talk about that reaction memory
so the key considerations is on a couple
of parameters which we'll discuss as far
as they are
important for your chest development and
we will talk about kepler rise time
about membrane backing about blocking
the membrane and about membrane
surfactants and we will come back to
that specific point later
very often the correct choice of the
membrane
uh will come down to the nature of the
nature of the test being designed and it
may be reasonable to test many product
variants
so capillary rise time what is that
that's the time that a liquid and
typically this is water needs to flow a
defined distance on the membrane and
typically this is 40 millimeters and
that's being used as in process controls
and memory manufacturing and it's what
we call a specification parameter
and at the lower left
of that slide you see what determination
of capillary flow time or capillary rise
time looks like
typically membranes are characterized by
a specification that has a specification
mean
for example 80 to 100 seconds for
a very fast membrane
and
um it has specification limits which we
will discuss in a minute very
uh fast membranes are being used for
things like saliva receptor will like
solids medium fast membranes which
typically have a flow time of
approximately 120 to 135 seconds as
specification means will be used for
things like blood serum and plasma or
for urine
and very slow membranes which have a
flow time of roughly 180 seconds will be
used for things like water
all suppliers manufactures the membrane
to a defined capillary rise time
and
that's our the main
specification parameter when we
manufacture membranes
while this capillary rise time
specification has an upper and a lower
limit
and that means you have to take care
that your reagents or your test results
are working the same way on both ends of
the specification limit
if you have an issue with membrane
specification parts at the fast end you
can easily see false negative results
the sample runs too quickly across the
membrane
and you do not see the result on the
test line that you would like to see at
the detection limit
if you have an issue with the slow part
of a membrane specification you may get
false positive signals or you will have
an issue with membrane clearance that
means the membrane is not white again
when the test duration time is over
in rare cases we see issues at both
edges of the specification and then it's
getting really difficult
um what you should do is you should test
membrane samples from both edges of the
specifications
something that we call limiting samples
and look for the performance of your
test
it might be that you have to select a
different membrane rate if you run into
trouble or it might be that you will
have to ask for a customized membrane a
membrane that works with your tests and
has its own capillary rise time
specifications
an important point here is that binders
are although they have the same affinity
constant
may be
different in terms of the on and off
rate of
are the binding reaction
for lateral flow tests you would be
interested in very fast on rates because
the interaction times that you have
available at the test line but also for
the conjugate
are very very short
antibodies that have the same affinity
but have slow on rates and slow off
rates are typically eliza antibodies
they will not work perfectly well in
lateral flow sa test
so if you have a bunch of antibodies
available
you should try to get surface plus one
resonance data that describes the only
afraid of the binders
if you have just one pair available and
no choice
uh for
selecting another reagent
you will have to play with the speed of
the membrane so
if you have to use binders that have
relatively slow on rate you will have to
use a slow membrane if you want to have
a chance
to reach your detection limit
membrane backing well what is that um
when you manufacture nitrocellulose
membranes
uh what is being done is the
nitrocellulose raw materials are
dissolved in organic solvents with
boiling points lower than that of water
uh these
casting mixes are poured onto a solid
sulfur surface typically a steel belt if
you want to have an unpacked membrane or
a plastic belt if you want to have a
back membrane
the membrane is formed on that support
and
in case of the back membrane
it's not lift lifted off the support
so it stays there
um the advantage is as mechanical
stability you will not be able to tear
that apart the disadvantage is you have
to live with the upper side of the
membrane and what that means you see on
the right part of that slide
uh what you see here is two electron
micrographs of an unbacked membrane
that's called a100
that's a fast uh electroflow membrane
and what you see that the upper side
which we call the air side has a
relatively coarse structure
um obviously a random structure which is
typical for nitrocellulose membranes
ah but the right side which is the bell
side the part of the membrane that was
forming directly on top of this support
steel belt
um has a denser structure which means a
higher protein binding capacity
and it looks more regular so it's not as
variable as the air side
if you want to use an unbacked membrane
use both sides and it could be very
advantageous to use than the bell site
the downside is the mechanical stability
of an unbacked membrane
and especially for beginners in the
field
our recommendation is use the back
memory
the nitrous cellulose matrix of the
membrane binds proteins and you like
that
you want this membrane to bind proteins
as long as you dispense your chest and
control lines
as soon as these binders have been bound
by the membrane you are left with an
awful lot of membrane area that's still
open has not bind anything yet
this membrane would bind
anything it would find in your sample
liquid your target
your detector reagent whatever you offer
and that means you will have to block
these three areas in order to prevent
them from interact
with your target or your detector
and there's two options
at first
you can do something
um that's called block on the fly in
that case blocking reagents are part of
the pre-treatment buffers of your sample
pad or your conjugate pad
these reagents are dissolved by the
sample liquid they migrate with the
sample
and block the membrane
while the sample liquid is moving across
the membrane and that's the reason why
it's called block on the fly
the advantage of this process is
a cost reduction
because the alternative is blocking in a
separate manufacturing step
in that case
um the membrane is
treated with
the tests and controlling reagents the
reagents are dried
and then the membrane is soaked
in a buffer or you spray
a buffer onto the membrane that contains
the blocking reagents
a separate manufacturing step means
another step that needs to be tested
developed validated
and of course it's the cost factor in
manufacturing
the advantage is you have full control
over the amount of blocking regions that
you apply to the membrane
if you do block on the fly you have to
live with the thickness variability of
the pads that are in front of the
membrane
and that means you will have different
concentrations of blocking reagents in
your migrating liquid
since you will have variable thickness
and it means variable pen volume but you
will always apply the same volume to
your cassette housing or your to your
dipstick and that means your sample
liquid is always the same it's always
the same volume
but the amount of molecules dissolved in
it
when it runs through the pads will
differ
that's especially difficult when you
want to develop
a quantitative test system
and for quantitative tests a
separate blocking step of the membrane
is more or less unavoidable
many people are not aware of the fact
that the reaction membrane contains a
surfactant
all nitrocellulose membranes contain
surfactants
and the surfactants are needed because
the nitrocellulose membranes are quite
hydrophobic matrices they only disaffect
and make them really hydrophilic
so surfactants have been a part in
nitrocellulose membranes since they're
very infancy and the oldest pattern that
i could find was from 1917 so it's more
than 100 years old and even that
membrane already contained as the fact
in
protein applications
not only letter flow but also flow
through tests or western blots
these surfactants help to mobilize your
binding proteins to the membrane matrix
different suppliers use different
surfactants and apply them at different
stations of the manufacturing process so
it makes sense to test membranes from
different suppliers
for your specific application
this
denaturation process
binds
proteins to membranes and you need that
the problem is
this process denatures proteins
it can easily be
that in the monoclonal antibody or the
female or the aptamer that you are using
the surfactant destroys the binding site
or at least reduces its activity
in that case you may have to switch to
another membrane that contains a
different surfactant or worst case
you may have
to look for different binders
i have worked with more than thousand
different monoclonal antibodies and all
kinds of other binders
um during my work in leftover flow
diagnostics
and
from what i've seen is two to three
percent of all monoclonal antibodies
that means two to three percent of the
clones
do not work on membranes because the
antigen binding sites are destroyed by
anionic surfactants
and in that case
although it's a rare case
there is no way out you can't make that
run on a nitrocellulose membrane and you
have to look for a different binder
but even if you can immobilize your
antibodies successfully
um you should keep in mind that
um
that this immobilization is a random one
that means the antibody is not bound
with its fc part to the membrane and the
antigen binding sites are protruding
into the free migrating liquid
any orientation of the antibody is
possible
and there's two things that you have to
look for one is is that a preferential
orientation that blocks the binding
sites because the binding sites binding
to the membrane in that case you have a
problem was the antibody antigen
interaction and the second question is
how close are the two binders
to each other once they bind to your
target
if they are too close you will run into
trouble with steric hindrance
especially in membranes that can easily
happen
and our recommendation is you should do
epitope mapping using surface plasmon
resonance to make sure that your
antibodies
are doing what they want them to do
without interfering with each other
it can also gives you reliable data
about on and off rates
and you could also test for
inconsistencies
from batch to batch and you can test
for
lack of compatibility with the use of
specific reagents
what you also have is pads on the left
and the right side
of the membrane
so you have a sample pad that you can
coat with buffers that may contain
reagents that
block the membrane but typically and
much more importantly they contain
reagents that take care that at least
some key parameters of your sample will
always look the same
after the sample has dissolved this
buffer that you have coated into the
sample pack
an example is urine
urine is coming with a quite acidic ph
in the morning and it's get gets
alkaline in the same
patient
towards the evening so a typical range
in ph is something between 6.5 and eight
what you can easily see that especially
specific binders like monoclonal
antibodies
change their binding characteristic when
you change the ph um it makes an awful
lot of sense to take care that every
urine regardless when it was collected
has the same ph when it runs across the
test and this is what you achieve in the
sample pattern
your sample pad may also be a blood
separator
as the name says it's being used when
you use whole blood as a sample and its
task is to remove the blood cells
especially the red blood cells
um still the main
detector particle electro flow rapid
test is gold gold nanoparticles and
that's red and if your red blood cells
leak onto your membrane you try to look
for a red signal on a red background and
it's not very likely to give you very
good signal to noise ratios and that is
what you why you need a blood separator
and then you have your conjugate pad
um that's the most tricky part of the
test to be honest
um because what you expected to do as
you expected to absorb the conjugate
path that you'll dispense on it
um and the liquid form and you
definitely should dispense and she
should not soak the pad with
the detector
then you dry the conjugate in the pad
and you would like this conjugate to
remain stable and not be destroyed
during the drying process
and then you expect after a year of
storage in
a drugstore a household a doctor's
office under more or less do these
environmental conditions
uh you in earnest expect the conjugate
pad
when the sample enters the conjugate pad
to release this dry conjugate into the
sample and make it run across the test
and
the detector reagent on the conjugate
uh is supposed to find structure to bind
it as it would do it um before you have
applied it to the pad
and that's a very
uh interesting expectation and
mistakes are during preparation of
conjugate spirits
are are the most likely root cause if
you run into trouble with your epic
chest
and finally you'll have an absorption
pad
often referred to as a wick
the task of this pad is to capture a
sample liquid
and to retain it
what you should take care of is that the
absorption capacity of this wick is much
larger than the volume of the sample
liquid that you apply because what you
have here is
a
matrix that generates your results
that's the membrane which is very thin
compared to all other pads
it will dry first and then you create a
concentration gradient
um and
what you can see then as a backflow from
the wake onto the membrane
which will give you all kinds of
unspecific
uh weird phenomena on the membrane and
you do not want that to happen you would
like to
have the membrane wide as long as
possible
um some faqs and some common issues
um very often
i'm asked what is the pore size of your
nitrocellulose membrane
in plastic membrane back membranes the
pore size cannot determine directly
that's due to the plastic backing
and that's the reason why all membrane
manufacturers refer to capillary rise
time or capillary flow time
uh as a specification parameter
as a rule of thumb a very fast membrane
has a very large pore size
um
and a given sample liquid will run
faster through a very fast membrane
uh than it does through a slow membrane
the point is depending on the properties
of your reagents especially if the
capture reagent on the test line
a fast membrane is likely to give you a
lower sensitivity as compared to a slow
membrane
um as said it depends also on the
properties of your capturing agents a
capture reagent with an extremely high
on rate gives you a very
good sensitivity even on a very fast
membrane
a capture reagent that has a disaster of
an on rate might not even work on the
slowest memory that you can buy in the
marketplace
another question is what adhesive is
used in your back membranes
no membrane manufacturer is using an
adhesive to create a plastic bag
membrane
these back membranes
are 100 micrometer thick polyester
supports onto which the casting mix is
poured and the membrane is for
on this polyester support and it stays
this by simple adhesion
um
adhesives come into play once you
laminate these membranes onto the
backing onto which you also have to fix
all the pads that you need to create
your wrapping test
a number of couple
a couple of issues as
listed on the right of the slides um
including possible solution so what is
frequently seen uneven lines or dots
during the dispensing process um you may
use different membranes with different
capillary flow times
um you may use the dispensing rate of
the reagent
perhaps including
reducing the dispensing volume if you do
that you may have to increase the
protein concentration of the reagent you
will take care of the buffer composition
and you will check your dispensing
process
and although many people don't like to
hear that um in a sizable number of
cases the reason for uneven
lines and dots is lack of maintenance of
the dispensers so it makes sense to
clean them properly and to take care of
their function
false positive signals
um
in terms of of membrane issues can be
modified uh by changing the buffer in
the conjugates are you make peak
uh tweak the ph to salt concentration
you may play around with surfactants
and worst case if that you have to
change a conjugated protein
for false negative results um
a typical solution would be
to
reduce the capillary rise time that
means to use a slower membrane this very
often leads to a better sensitivity
of a test
increasing the sample volume is also an
option
but there are limits to that in the
lateral flow test
so the typical sample volume is 100
microliters you can use something like
two perhaps 300 microliters the idea to
run one milliliter across a lateral flow
test
is simply not feasible so there is an
upper limit to that
uh what is also sometimes seen as uneven
liquid fronts of migrating samples
it might be that you have stored your
membrane too long
but in most cases
it's a problem with either
that you're using a relatively
hydrophobic membrane that means a
membrane that has
a very low surfactant content
and the other option is that you have a
problem with the relative humidity in
the room and if this is too low uh then
you will see flow issues
another question worth
the hydrophobicity of membranes
is a very interesting one
um hydrophobic membranes or let's say
membranes that have a low surfactant
content they're not really hydrophobic
can easily give you better better
sensitivities because they have a less
negative impact on your binders
especially on the test line um you can
modify
the
uh hydrophilicity of the membrane then
by
playing around with the blocking muscle
so a membrane that is relatively
hydrophobic and you like that because it
gives you a better sensitivity should be
blocked in a separate manufacturing step
because then you can deal with
uh any uneven liquid fronds or migration
issues that you see and still have a
better sensitivity
than you would have with a high
surfactant memory
so to summarize that uh the
nitrocellulose membrane is the core of
your electro flow essay because this is
where the end user sees the test result
getting the right membrane first time or
at least
as soon as possible is key in
keeping your letter flow test
development and on track within
specification and on budget
um choosing a membrane is not just
simply using a paper
it needs to be considered alongside a
lot of other key decisions and it has to
be done
in our conjunction with reagent
selection
the membrane needs to be able to
immobilize antibodies it should not
affect their binding capabilities
and it must enable sample to flow at the
optimal speed
and it makes a lot of sense to work
closely with your membrane manufacturer
to discuss our common pitfalls
or to discuss
uh what can be done and what cannot be
done with a given set of reagents
uh and perhaps to design in a membrane
that's manufactured according to your
needs
and if you have questions please feel
free to talk to us thank you
thank you claus for that outstanding
presentation we will now move into the
live q a portion of the presentation
claus will unfortunately not be able to
join us for this portion but we do have
lee jenkins joining us senior product
leader for sativa
welcome lee
and i just want to remind our audience
members to please submit their questions
via the q a box
looks like we already have some great
questions coming in lee
so let's get started
our first question is what are the
common reasons why people fail to
develop a viable test
okay yes thank you and
yeah distribute apologies to everybody
that close can't be here
for the q a session
but um hopefully i can help answer these
questions and anything you wish to
discuss with us we can take offline
so with regards to the common reasons
why people fail close they did a
excellent job
in the video i'm talking about different
reasons but essentially
you know i think to summarize what he
presented
there are many different factors
involved in developing the test
so it could be anything from the
detection here
um your detection reagents reagent use
which pads membranes you select
the backing card selections or even the
working environment and equipment set up
so every single factor involved will
affect the overall performance and test
so in terms of test development failure
it really does depend case by case
and you know we can help you with your
troubleshooting if you need this support
but um we support that we suggest that
look at maybe the capture region
selection or
the texture selection and regions of the
tests are probably a key place to start
but
unfortunately you'd have to test all of
those items
thank you so much lee
our next question why does the test take
so long to develop for example the
covid19 test
golden question
so everybody wants of the quicker
development and
[Music]
to develop a normal lasso flow test can
take two to three years to keep a
customer get from development get
through clinical trials and get onto the
market
and two probably
a good robust test you know normally you
take an absolute minimum of one year at
the r d phase
so let's go through the whole tech
transfer and scale up after that the
stability trials obviously requires time
as well
so everyone's working with absolute
urgency
um doing the kind of pandemic get test
as quick as possible
but you know we need to allow type
development for the optimization in
order to fulfill all the needs um
understanding cod is a special situation
and we do have some emergency use
authorization to bypass some of the
timelines
but you know it still takes time to go
for such a complex development and
hopefully klaus is 30 minutes this
presentation you know touched on
some of the elements of why they take
quite so long to complete the process
thank you so much lee can you talk to
the audience a little bit about the
development of challenges of
multiplexing
okay yeah that's another good question
so
i guess first of all there's several
different types of multiplexing assays
so you could have a array of strips
you could have spatial separation or
detection sites
you could have a broad selective
recognition element or you could have a
variable signal reporter
and the primary consideration when
contemplating multiplexing in a later
flow essay would be about the cross
reactivity and interference between the
assays because
this might impact your signal
the sample treatment
method compatibility
the sensitivity and dynamic range of
each part of the test um each of the
targets that we try to detect
the
stability and you know the assay format
you know it is a mix of sandwich i see
it's involved then this has a whole
extra level of complexity
when
talking about a multiplex i see you know
a membrane which never shallows you
select is a key element
so
we suggest that when developing mother
effects that flow i see they need to
consider upfront the number of test legs
they require
the viscosity of the sample
the desired or at the very least the
acceptable test runtime
the kinetic properties of the cutting
regions and then
as close touched on the list the memory
inspectors must be very important
and that would need tested and something
a different membrane what works well
with your rsa
thank you so much i want to thank our
audience members for these great
questions coming in
lee what blocking agents are typically
used and how does the impact
um how does this impact flow rate for
example
okay
so normally we block our conjugate parts
and let's tell those membranes for the
conjugate parts the purpose of the
blocking is to make the conjugate stable
during the whole shelf life of the test
so make your conjugate release
efficiency
and you know repeat the both from the
conjugate part
you can start to block your conjugate
parts by you know
developing several different um
formations so
we have a standard process of a
boring a psa buffer that we use but
i'd suggest that if you're in contact
with our
teams after the meeting we can help
share some details of what we've used
previously
but people need to keep in mind that
different part materials
and different tests will require
different buffers so there's not one
bespoke solution which is why i'm a
little bit hesitant to
share too much on this question
with regards to the nightmare cellulose
the purpose of blocking the membrane is
to reduce the unspecific binding of
protein
so different concentrations of bsa can
be tested as a blocking buffer here to
see how the
impact is on your protest
thank you so much and how do you start
to evaluate membranes based on what
surfactant can they use
okay so
yeah i think clouds did
again a session on this but the
surfactant is a very important factor of
night cellulose
you know he mentioned that all labor
cellulose is on the market hundreds of
atoms present
generally different types so
you need to understand that not all
monoclonal antibodies will work well in
a presence of a given surfactant
that's plant body testing in the
presence of various surfactants and
it's critical to optimize the
performance
so we've got you know a feeling i would
say that about three percent of my
problems bodies will not work in the
presence of any surfactant
so others may only work at low surface
uh
low surfactant concentrations
so it's getting very much around that
testing evaluating you know trying to
test and broaden the range as possible
during your
early development stages
um different surfactants in the
membranes may lead to different test
results so
you may get changes in sensitivity
you know positive or negative um
influences on your test or you may get
false positives if you
are not compatible so that's really key
to the testing elements and then also
the way this factors introduce the
membrane can have a big influence on the
results
so we have different product families at
city of neptulos where
the majority of our grades such as the
ffhp grades
we add surfactants the cast in mix
and we do this because we believe that
it gives a more consistent mix of
distractions to the membrane
some other
product families that we release or that
our competitors have available they
post treat the product after
manufacturers the fact that
again it can have a different impact on
your performance positive or negative so
we encourage you to test
both to see what works well for yourself
but you know it may lead to more
variability or less
consistency of surfactant
you use a post-treated membrane
the type of surfactants concentration of
the spectrums they're all proprietary to
each membrane supplier so they're not
going to necessarily tell you what's the
fact that's included but you know we
suggest if you talk to our application
specialists they can give you more
information on you know what they
regard regarding our memory interactions
and what could work for your test
wonderful thank you so much
emily what are the scale-up factors that
one needs to consider during the test
development
so before i answer this i guess the
the best answer for today is there's a
session later in the summit about
scaling up your development so
we've got arvind health talking about
the importance of a contract
manufacturing organization and talking
to them early in your development so
join john's session
today to understand exactly what's
involved there
we also have five dots coming on at the
end of the event to talk about how they
can bring scale of the test
but
from our side as a component supplier
well we suggest that you choose
materials from high quality suppliers
with
you know appropriate levels of technical
support
ensure the membranes you are putting
available at a large scale and that
there's no capacity concerns
that's especially critical at the moment
because around copper 19 we see in
you know some suppliers are having a run
on memory of the
normal level of availability that they
would have had previously
consider dispensing remembering reaches
to non-contact methods
so this can just help your
automation and the volume possible
immersion processes if possible
use conveyance conjugates which are
appropriately optimized and stabilized
uh whatever suggestions i got um
use inline processing and automated
process controls
use a controlled manufacturing
environment and then in your development
concentrate on appropriate device design
and assembly method so that you've got a
test which can go from a lab-based test
into a full automation skill test
again if anyone needs any support over
these skill conversations
you know please speak to our teams they
can help pay you on suggestions of what
we can provide you
thank you so much lee
and thank you again to our audience this
next audience member
poses a question
from their own lab and hopefully can get
some assistance from you
he writes besides we consider the
capillary flow of the membrane is there
any other factor which could help to
control the capillary speed for example
they have a problem with their capillary
flow right now and that their assay is
too fast and they've tried to add
surf surfactants or even blockers for
the membrane but it wasn't significant
can you help them with this problem
i can but also i'd suggest that you know
if they want to reach out to
any of our contacts or any other field
application support teams they can
discuss stay specifically
but at a high level the advice i can
give is that the surfactant generally
will not help slow down
the reflow type this is not something
that the spark that brings to the
membrane
lock-in can help a little bit but again
not
a huge um contribution the most
significant way of affecting the flow
rate would be
looking at the membrane
and the
pods that you use the assay
so the wick and the sample conjugate
parts and what is the working rate of
those but also what's the photon of the
megacellos the tri
pads and membranes which have a
slower rating for the working and
complete flow times so all membranes and
parts are released with
membrane speeds
so talk to your supplier understand
what they have um
what memories you have now where that is
in the
the range and try to select something
with a higher reading it's a higher
measurement which gives you a slower
lower membrane
you can even talk to your map your
supplier and see if you know
if you seem to fit in between two parts
you're not getting a correct level of
sensitivity let's see if they give you a
custom flow membrane which is the higher
end of a specification due to the test
now outside of that it's probably
looking at the affinity binding rate of
your detection pay
you know you need to go back to do
something like spr analysis to
understand your own operates
using vehicle or something similar but
you know this can often mean we started
the whole development process and
you know we were just looking at the
parts and remembering your first simple
step
wonderful thank you so much i hope that
helps her
our next question can the choice of
antibody type
for example antibodies optomers
affirmers
affect the flexibility of choice of nc
membranes and ultimately the speed of
the assay
yeah um
another one where it really depends so
typically the capture reagents will work
differently with different pollutants
and sparkling types
i wouldn't say that there is any
restriction or flexibility around choice
but it goes back to you know demand for
doing development test as many different
varieties as possible
when you're selecting your membrane to
departs you know test different families
different speeds
to understand what performance you're
getting if you're able to take to test
your affinity binding of the pair you
know via the spl analysis which you know
i just mentioned vehicles a way of doing
that then again it can help you
understand
what capability you have in your chest
but unfortunately it's going to be a
trial and error activity for the
customer
thank you so much we have time for a few
more questions
is it possible to obtain
a highly sensitive and quick reaction by
changing the antibody type
rather than the membrane test itself
membrane itself
yeah
okay so
if you have a test which is running a
present with a
antibody and you're looking just to
switch that over to the activator
that's highly unlikely because it's you
know very rare in natural flow and the
test that you are able to make a simple
swap out of one component to another
especially something as critical as the
detection regions
um
you probably would have to go back
through the whole redevelopment and
essentially it becomes developing a new
test
looking at different protection types
you could get faster speeds and you
might need
um
you know a more sense you might get a
more sensitive assay but it all really
depends on
your thinking binding rate and how it's
compatible from your all components in
your test
so again
not the direct answer but it's very
specific if you have a test that you
want to help you talk to again i
encourage you to contact one of our team
offline we can have discussions with you
but um it's not a
one-size-fits-all solution to this
answer
thank you so much lee
now if we inject for example two
proteins into a membrane
but when checked only one protein
appears
what does one do and
whether do they replace the membrane or
the process for the protein that must be
correct
yeah and
it's all good to discuss very specific
cases such as this in a general format
but know in more detail
i don't want to keep referring to the
same response but you know if
the customer
process we can
separate and talk a lot more detail
about their tests and understand
exactly what they're doing to
you know consider all aspects um from a
high level
it's quite all you know but it's good to
see what could be
thank you so much
yeah of course yes when you're after the
321
no problem
how do you minimize serum
interference in the serology
lfa okay so the simplest way of
minimizing interference is by having a
good blood separator
um clouds touched on in a presentation
very briefly
that separate is available but
you should essentially try different um
sample volumes and different separators
to understand what would be your test
there is a
lot of information out there and
different suppliers do have different
separators if you need more advice and i
advise person to look through to the
saikiva website where we do have some
content around
what different separators and
how this can work within their tests so
encourage you to get in contact if you
need samples from us to
see what works well and we can happily
supply these to you
thank you so much
nelly our next audience member has a
question about validity and reliability
if things like humidity and the shelf
life of the membrane can impact the test
and assuming packaging can mitigate this
to an extent but not completely
would the typical validation line at the
end of the test be the only method to
determine a faulty test and if so how
reliable will it be
very interesting
so
the validation line i assume you mean
the control line uh so yes this would be
you know obviously
your north star as we say so this would
be your
ultimate way of understanding once the
test is developed now if it's failed but
i would go back to that this is all
about development this question so
ensuring that you have a rigorous
development that you are fully
testing the stability during your
early processes that you are
understanding the capability of your
assay
you don't want to do this once you've
got through development and you've got a
product on the market if you're relying
on a control line tell your
the test is faulty or not you know
you're in serious trouble you want to
understand all of this very early in the
process understand the shuffling for
your conjugates how stable they are when
suspended someone's stride understands
the stability of your whole test and the
only way to do this is by stability
trials and a rigorous development
process
thank you so much and again
what a great lively conversation from
our audience today
what are the reasons for getting those
ghost bands with capture antibody on the
top test line and how do i get rid of it
again it's one that sounds very specific
to this customer's essay so hard to give
a
an answer which is going to be
definitive you
so
again feel free to contact our team's
offline where we can help discuss this
but um
clouds outlined in the presentation some
ways where we have
you know faint lines or these post
it's all generally about looking at your
not specific finding or having a look at
your
dispensing rates around the test
it's something which
you know
we could have talked more details
offline but very difficult to get
exploring kind of give you a definitive
answer on what would work first
unfortunately
wonderful thank you and the same
audience member wants to know what is
the optimum capture antibody
concentration for the test line
yeah again it's going to be very
specific to your test uh what on the
bodies you're using what you're trying
to detect
not able to give you a definitive answer
on that in this forum um
if we want to talk about we can give you
some examples of
you know what concentrations we use for
different targets and we can say from
our experience what works well but such
a broad
um
statement across that whole muscle flow
very difficult
we have time for one more question
we i have a problem
this is coming from an audience member i
have a problem with
assay sensitivity and suggested to add
stacking pads on it could you recommend
some suitable properties for the
stacking pad and should we treat the
stacking pad with a buffer for example
yeah um
so if you've got sensitivity
issues in your test then this could help
but no by no means it's gonna be the
only solution for you
um
difficult again to understand without
knowing what your test is um
important considerations when you look
at your part would be what working rates
you want or what absorbency you want
from your pad
um
no you might want a buffer whether the
chase buffer or whether you want the
blocking solution
they could help but again we really
would need to understand your specific
essay you know let's comment in more
detail over what would be appropriate
for this test unfortunately
thank you so much lee jenkins we are out
of time i want to thank you would you
like to provide any closing remarks to
our audience before we close today
yes just uh thank you for being joined
in um you know i've mentioned quite a
few times that
there's not a
one-size-fits-all answer for everything
and it is very case-specific
so
you know please i encourage all our
customers if they are interested we are
more than happy to continue this
conversation offline get in contact with
your local account managers or your
local field application support and we
can help um
talk more specific to you
thank you thank you
thank you again sir and i want to thank
claus for his time as well and i want to
thank our audience for their outstanding
questions and their participation just
as a reminder any questions that were
submitted but not answered today by our
speaker will be addressed via email
and this presentation will be available
for on-demand viewing for 12 months
please remember to share it with your
colleagues who may have been interested
in this topic but missed today and don't
miss out on the other presentations on
our agenda visit the agenda tab
in the auditorium for a full listing
take care and thank you again for your
participation
until next time stay safe and stay
healthy bye